is the kind of threat that Israeli
forces cannot prevent Lone Wolf attacks
that happen suddenly and randomly this
time underwater front Promenade in Tel
Aviv
police are calling it a combined ramming
and shooting attack
in the chase the car overturned
the alleged perpetrator got out but was
killed on the spot a few meters away
police say the attacker was a 44 years
old man a Palestinian Israeli from
Central Israel with no criminal record
one Italian tourist a man said to be in
his 30s was killed and several other
tourists wounded hours earlier prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu and his
defense minister were in the Jordan
Valley on the site of another similar
attack a Palestinian opened fire on a
car before managing to escape killing
two sisters their mother remains in
critical condition I can only say one
thing our enemies are putting us to the
test again and once again they will
discover even in this test that we stand
together United confident in our
righteousness and we will act together
with the complete support of our forces
the IDF and the security forces the
Prime Minister said that Manhunt was
underway to capture the attacker in
retaliation Jewish settlers fled to the
streets in various parts of the occupied
West Bank here they are seen harassing
Palestinians driving near Ramallah do
you an efforts for humanitarian Affairs
says that on average there are three
daily attacks on Palestinians or their
properties since the beginning of the
year
all this comes at a time when there's
widespread anger among Palestinians
triggered by violent police raids inside
El axamos
this pillow will threatened to broaden
the conflict after a barrage of rockets
were fired from both Lebanon and Gaza
and Israel carried out airstrikes in
retaliation
tensions are still simmering along those
borders shortly after the Tel Aviv
attack the Prime Minister instructed
both the police and the Army to mobilize
all Reserve units but he's a man who is
coming under pressure from many fronts
from within his own Coalition where some
are calling for a tougher stance from
many Israelis who oppose his attempts to
change the judicial system and from
Israel's closest Ally the U.S which in a
rare move publicly expressed concern
over the Judiciary overhaul the man who
for so long imposed himself as a tough
Mr security Now Limited in his choices
in occupied East Jerusalem